net neutrality part of the telecoms
package is meant to ensure that
broadband and mobile phone providers
give equal bandwidth for all internet
sites the new rules have divided the
left and the right but parliament's
rapporteur maintains that net neutrality
is safeguarded under the legislation
with this proposal we have reinforced
the openness of internets explain
that all traffic should be treated
equally independently of the center
independently of the the one that
received without discrimination without
interference but those who defend the
internet rights of citizens don't hold
the same view for example
orange
the package of reforms goes to plenary
in april
there are about 1.5 million posted
workers in europe they work on a
temporary basis in member states with
very little social protection and at the
same time the people that employ them
are getting cheap labor and taking the
business away from local businesses
that's why meps and the council have
reached an agreement and come up with an
eu director that better provides
protection for these posted workers and
makes it easier for member states to
monitor them the aim is to avoid any
attempt to circumvent the law the tax
has been defended by the employment
committee
there is the obligation for member
states to control a
hosting company there are a list of
control measures and also members say
they can establish new
control measures if this one which we
recommend today is not efficient if
adopted member states will then have
until 2016 to implement these rules